My name is David Aja.
I'm a member of the Solutions
Engineering team at RStudio.
Or, if you prefer,
I posit solutions.
I help data scientists get
their ideas into production,
and in the course
of doing that work,
I see a lot of broken things.
And so that's why today I'll
be talking about why I think
you should use renv... probably.
So there are two
parts to this talk.
The first part is
going to be about why
I think you should do this.
And then in the second
part, we'll talk about how.
But let's start with why.
And I think the reason that
I'm kind of up here giving
this talk is because I think
we have a standards problem.
And the way I would express
that standards problem is
that I don't know if we have
a good answer to the following
question, which is
what makes a project
an R project?
We're probably going
to need to define
some terms in order
to make our way through that.
So let's start with project.
What is a project?
This is the definition you
get if you Google it, right.
We've got an individual or
a collaborative enterprise
aimed at a particular aim.
I think that's a pretty
helpful definition,
but sometimes I like
to try to define
things functionally right.
A thing is what it does.
And so what do projects do?
Projects ship.
This is a slightly
unusual way of talking.
It's kind of a legacy of our
history of writing software
to physical media and then
mailing it to your house.
But this is kind of
the paradigm that we
have in mind when we talk
about shipping projects, right?
We've worked on something.
I have it.
I need to get it to you.
And I want you to have
a particular experience.
Some of you may be thinking
about a particular like file
extension that maybe
is like you're like it
says that kind of thing.
And there.
And so I'll just say
like the, I think
the, .Rproj or
RStudio project file
is not going to be sufficient
for our purposes here.
And part of the reason that's
true is because what's in the
RStudio project file is editor
configuration and editor editor
configuration is
important to you.
But when you send data analysis
results, data, data analysis
results to someone,
they typically
don't ask you how many spaces
you put in a tab, right?
And so the idea is you don't
ship your editor. A thing
I think it's important
to say, all right,
I'm making a lot of
declarative statements
here, like part of this is from
a history of screwing things
up pretty catastrophically.
So I have actually
shipped my editor
and then I ended up debugging
my code in our general counsel's
office.
And that's not where I
want any of you to be.
Right? so I think we have
to look for some better
ways of doing work.
All right.
So the RStudio project file
is going to be necessary
if you use RStudio.
And I think an important
thing to acknowledge,
even though this
is RStudio::conf
is that not everyone
does use RStudio.
The RStudio project
file is necessary,
but for the purpose
of helping us
understand what a
project is, it's
not going to be sufficient.
So we have to look elsewhere
for a definition of what
a project is.
And one of the things that I
found really inspiring when
I was trying to figure out
how to more reliably deliver
software, was a website
called 12factor.net.
This website was
published by people
who work on the deployment
platform, Heroku,
which helped people deploy
a software as a service
applications to the public.
But a lot of the lessons that
they publish there, I think,
are useful even in the
data professional context.
And one of the things
they really stress
is the importance of
environment isolation, right?
So the 12 factor apps never
rely on the implicit existence
of system wide packages.
And there are a couple
of things that they
say are important to
making this happen, right?
So you have to declare
all your dependencies
and then you have to isolate
them from other things
on the system.
And you have to make sure that
no implicit dependencies leak
in.
And I want to dwell on the
leak in thing for a moment,
because I'm going to give
a sort of stylized example
from my past to show you how
this kind of thing can happen.
Right? so let's say,
you know, or let's say
I was working on
a project, I did
a lot of work on the 2020
census for an advertising agency
I worked on at the time, and
I delivered some dashboard
and people looked at the
results and it was good.
And then someone asked me
to do some data analysis
on the census tract level.
It needed to do
between a 1 and 7
day look back there, like
80,000 census tracts.
We were doing data
for, data analysis
for, at that point, several
months worth of data.
And so I was like, OK,
I need to do something.
This might be a good case
for the latest dtplyr.
And so I installed dtplyr.
I was able to work
on the analysis
and everything was fine.
Except I accidentally
by installing dtplyr,
upgraded the version
of the dplyr that
was being used in my dashboard.
Because the thing I
haven't highlighted so far
is that we have a dependency
on a shared user library.
The answer is not in production.
And so I think I'm
going to borrow
Julia's excellent
metaphor from yesterday.
We want to find a way
of working that stops it
from being possible for us
to lock our keys in the car.
So let's talk about
how we do that, right?
The first step is going to be
to isolate your dependencies.
And so in order
to do that, you're
going to need to
install the renv package
and then you're going
to initialize it.
You have a couple of
options for doing that.
You can call the init function.
There's also a
little box you can
check as you're creating a
new project in the rstudio IDE
and that will create and
this will sort of overwrite
your .libPaths, right?
So by default you have kind
of a user library and a system
library and renv will take
that over and say, OK,
now you have a project
specific library and then
your system library.
And so what that looks
like, if we go back in time,
I properly isolate my libraries.
I have this user
library and my dashboard
and then the project library
gets the upgraded versions,
right?
And that means that if I start
working on new projects right,
say I start doing experimental
things with new packages
and tidymodels.
I'm not really concerned
about breaking other things
in my workflow.
Right and the other thing
that's nice to note here,
right, is that you can adopt
this incrementally, right?
So you don't have to move
all of your projects at once.
You can see that my
dashboard is still
pointing in my user library.
I can go and upgrade
that surgically
later on if I want to.
And you might be asking
yourself, OK, well, you're
making me maintain
this isolated library.
Does that mean I need to
reinstall every package
from scratch each time?
The answer is no.
renv maintains
a package cache.
So once you install the
package, it's available to you
to reuse in other projects if
they have the same dependency.
So that first installation
might take a little bit of time,
but the subsequent installations
will go much faster.
Once we've isolated the
dependencies on our system,
the next thing we need to do
is to discover what they are
and write that down
somewhere, right?
And so calling the renv
snapshot function
is going to give us some
information about the versions
of packages we use
and which ones we have,
where we got those
packages from,
because as we heard, shared
drives RStudio Package Manager,
r-universe, all of
these are different places
where you can get R
packages and so you
want to be able to keep
track of where you got them
as well as the version of R you
were using for your project.
Right and so you
can see here this
is a package I've installed
from the r-universe,
and we're so keeping
track of the information
about the Git commits, right?
And we're writing all of this
down in the renv lock file.
And I think the
renv.lock file
is the project artifact
that we're looking for.
Part of the thing that is
going to enable us to do
is to collaborate
more effectively.
And so renv is itself very
helpful in giving you
status messages about
what you need to do next.
And this is going to be
really helpful for context
where either you're
picking up an old project
or you're sharing a
project with a teammate who
doesn't have the same package
set on their computer.
So you can see in this case,
I've installed some packages
or I've pulled down a
lock file and the packages
are in the lock file, but
they're not yet on my system.
And renv is going
to tell me what to do.
This is a similar
kind of situation
where I started using a package,
but I haven't installed it yet.
Calling renv::status()
is again going to tell me
what to do to get right.
Right and if I remove a
package from my project,
then I want to remove those
dependencies as well because I
don't want to ship unnecessary
things to my deployment
target, whatever that is.
Right and so this is going
to be the workflow, right?
We're going to initialize
a project in renv
we'll install the
packages we need,
we snapshot, we ship
and then later we
can restore that
environment once we
have the project in renv.
Right install snapshot
ship and restore.
I did say "probably"
at the beginning
there are a couple of
things where this may not
apply to you.
One, I'll call it a bad
argument and one better one.
I don't intend to
reuse this code.
This is too much.
This is too much overhead.
I think one of the
things about being
a data professional, right,
is that you are in fact, going
to have to reuse the code.
Right someone is
going to ask you, hey,
I got numbers from finance
that don't match yours.
What's going on?
Can you rediscover that?
And you're just
like, you're going
to be in that
cycle of iteration.
And so this is a tweet
I pulled from somebody
who is talking
about this as I was
avoiding working on this talk.
And I think it really perfectly
encapsulates that, like,
if you just treat things
like they're throwaway,
they're going to come back
and you should just work
like your work is valuable.
If you are purely a
package developer,
then you are in a somewhat
different circumstance
because the execution target is
not necessarily getting someone
to call your Plumber API.
It's CRAN reverse
dependency checks.
renv does have some
tools that you can use
to isolate environments
if you need
to do specialized testing and
the article on that in the renv
documentation is
pretty excellent,
as is the rest of
renv's documentation.
So in summary, I think we have
an opportunity here to coalesce
on a project standard.
I encourage you
all to use renv
and I want to say a special
Thank you to Kevin,
without whose work, none
of this would be possible.
Thank you.